[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
[Applause]
hi table family i just want to say thank
you
and welcome to this opportunity just to
be able to
talk to you to share with you guys i
hope you guys have had a
fantastic week um and that
um just that we are so glad that you are
here so glad that you could join us
be able to be able to participate with
us
be able to worship with us and be able
to connect with us in a meaningful way
we love that you're here last week i had
the opportunity
of meeting some of our new members
of the table family and oh my goodness
it was
a great experience just on my end i was
able to
it was interesting to be able to kind of
connect with people
that have never even walked in our doors
and be able to see and to feel
not just the love of christ but the
connection that i've always felt
about this community just how welcoming
and inviting that you
you all are and that is not something
that is just done
by only simply the leadership that is
something that's done with
every single person that is a part of
this community um so i want to just say
thank you so much for
you guys just being so amazing and so
awesome i've always felt that just being
a part of
part of this community and that's one of
the reasons why i continue to come
every single sunday and you guys are
amazing so thank you thank you
thank you so much um so anyway with that
being said i've got a couple
announcements
to do with you all um the very first one
is something pretty basic um is to
simply just
go and vote um in texas early voting
just started this last week
we still have a few more weeks of that
before the actual
day of the election so if you haven't
had a chance to
make a time in your schedule in your
in your busy work lives and things like
that try to make a plan to do so
um it's so important for you to exercise
that
we we have that opportunity to do so so
make sure you go vote
the second thing as we have mentioned
before
so the e3 conference is coming up this
week so it is coming up it's gonna be
thursday night
friday and saturday morning
so if you haven't had a chance to
register i know the link for that is
going to be below in the comments
if you haven't had a chance to do so
this is a good time to
do that now take advantage of that um
also i might be doing one of the
breakout sessions but that's not the
reason why you need to be going
this is a good opportunity for folks to
if you don't know too much about maybe
the lgbt
community you have a lot of questions
about what this is
maybe you don't even know where you fall
on that whole entire thing about whether
you're affirming not affirming
or you don't even know what to think
about this this is a good place
just to kind of find people who are
still trying to figure that out for
themselves
so this is an excellent place it is a
local place that's here in the dallas
area
but it is going to be online this year
so you can access any of the information
i think for a full six months after the
registration and then still be able to
view all the materials that's there
so it is going to be online this year so
check it out the last thing i want to
remind you
is that we are having our one year
anniversary
and the first sunday in november
november 1st
so make sure if you haven't marked your
calendars for that
to make a point to mark your calendars
we're going to do an in-person
event it's going to be awesome it's
going to be great to be able to see
people's face to face
and to get reconnected um
with folks and everything so anyway with
all of that being said i know there's a
lot of information
i'm going to we're going to segue into
worship but before we do that
i just want to pray for you all
lord thank you so much um for
the people at the table thank you so
much for this group
and thank you so much for us our the
having the ability to continue to
be able to meet this way uh to be able
to connect with people's lives for
the way that um it's this is a still a
very
meaningful way of connecting with folks
um i pray
for those who are listening whether
they're listening right now
live or whether tuning in later that
you'll just open up their hearts and
minds to
where they are to what you have for them
to um what you were wanting to
communicate with them today
or tonight lord i pray for um
for brett as he speaks later on tonight
as for mindy and maggie as they lead
worship
and all the different pieces that go on
tonight i just pray that
your will will just reach out and just
fulfill the hearts of
people with her listing and all these
things in christ i pray
amen
amen thanks don i loved your shameless
plug for your breakout
we were definitely laughing at you hey
that's enough reason for me to want to
go
i'm like all right well that seals the
deal right there
i also just wanted to quickly apologize
for the degradation of my screen
view i've heard a few people comment on
it and i hope it's not distracting
i'm very sorry and um
it is in the process of well
don't get her started yeah it's a
soapbox that i shouldn't get on right
now
because we're headed into worship and it
will definitely put me in the wrong
headspace
but i'm really glad that you guys are
joining us i wanted to say really
quickly we're
um we're gonna go through a few songs
tonight that are all kind of
um building to the gift of the gospel of
jesus
laying down his life um on behalf of
those
who didn't always uh
deserve it or weren't even looking for
it but just this this sacrificial love
of that we see on the cross and and
really the love that we
want i want to pattern my life after
and um i just want to invite you tonight
um as we're as we're singing these songs
if they're familiar with you
obviously um i hope that they resonate
in your heart that you're singing along
even inwardly or outwardly wherever
you're at whatever you're comfortable
with
but if they're not familiar with you i
hope that the lyrics
um take you to a place where you are
where you find yourself opening up to
this creator god
who with intentionality and purpose
spun this crazy world into motion
and you are a part of that you are a
part of this spinning of this cycle of
of what's going on here and um i watched
documentary this week that my brother
actually was begging us to watch a life
on planet earth
by david somebody i'm so sorry i'm bad
at references but
it really it really was kind of this
overwhelming feeling
of just the intentionality of creator
god
and um and i just found myself like this
teeny tiny little grain of sand
um in the in the whole realm of it all
you know um and just the beauty and
the purpose behind all of it and um
anyways it just drew me into this
appreciation
um for that creativity and that we see
around us for this world that we live in
and then kind of reflecting on my part
and
sometimes it may seem so small but i
hope that my part
leaves behind footprints of love and
leaves behind um footprints of sacrifice
even maybe when no one no one is asking
for it or
maybe even when there are relationships
that don't seemingly deserve it um
but i hope that i am weaving into this
grand tapestry
a little bit more love and forgiveness
and grace and
um i'm so grateful for that example in
christ
and in the gospel story um that we're
swept up in
so i hope that that finds its way into
your home tonight or
whatever space you're in so you guys
join in with us as you can
[Music]
of time
with no point of reference
you spoke to the dark and fleshed out
the wonder of life
[Music]
and as you speak
a hundred billion galaxies are born
[Music]
in the vapor of your bread the planet
i can see your heart and everything
you've made
[Music]
if creation sings your praise is so
light
[Music]
you don't speak in vain
for once you have spoken
all nature and science follow the sound
of your voice
and as you speak
a hundred billion creatures catch a
breath
evolving in pursuit
i can see your heart and everything
[Music]
if creation still obeys you so
alright
[Music]
soul
is
[Music]
100 billion times
god of salvation
you chased down my heart through all of
my
failure and pride
on a hill you created
the light of the world abandoned in
darkness
[Music]
and as you speak
a hundred billion failures disappear
you lost your life so i could find it
here if you left
the grave behind you so light
i can see your heart in everything
you've done
[Music]
i can see your heart a billion different
ways
every precious
[Music]
100 billion times but what measure could
amount to your
desire
you're the one who never leaves
we've seen how sing hallelujah
we sing hallelujah
[Music]
his perfect is
is
[Music]
hallelujah
we sing hallelujah
it's running after me
[Music]
is
your goodness is
[Music]
thank you god for the way that we
see you inviting us into this
love journey into this process
of becoming more and more like jesus
[Music]
thank you for the things that you've
woven in
to the tapestry of this world from its
origin from its beginnings
this story of beauty and redemption
this way of grace
this rhythm
that even around us in creation we see
your beauty
forming even out of dust even
out of destruction even out of
nothingness sometimes
we find this light of god
welling up and bringing about change
bringing about truth and revelation
and creation and beauty around us god
[Music]
would we allow that to be woven into our
story
into our lives god
would we follow the way of grace the way
of jesus
[Music]
the way of radical and sacrificial love
thank you for who you are and thank you
for this life that you've given us
we wanna be in it god
it's in your name i pray amen
amen thank you maggie and mindy and
before them
dawn um well good evening everyone
grace and peace welcome to the table
uh i want you to know that no matter who
you are
where you're from uh regardless of your
background
your your race your gender your sexual
orientation
um no matter how good or bad you
perceive yourself to be
uh whether you were and just this week
you knocked out of the park you were
such a winner
or maybe this week uh you just you feel
like you did nothing but fail
um regardless of all of that uh you are
wanted you're welcome
uh with us tonight so thank you so much
for for joining us
um even as this pandemic drags
on forever and we're still online
but you know what i'm grateful is way
better than nothing
for sure so we are in um
right now this is part four of our
series titled scripture
dealing with difficult texts and um in
this series we're
basically we're just kind of jumping
straight into
uh a lot of passages that might be
kind of just more comfortable to avoid
uh
and so tonight i hope um i was thinking
all week just about this message and i'm
like
i hope i'm not overcooking people's
grits because you know this
this series just kind of the nature of
it it's basically you know week after
week after we just this barrage of
really hard-hitting topics um
and you know uncomfortable passages i
guess that's the
that's the series right difficult texts
so i hope you don't forget in the midst
of this
there's plenty that's beautiful about
the bible
but this series is just not so focused
on those
um but you know for because of that i
really think this is a very very
important series
um you know people walk away from the
faith over the things we're we're
tackling in this
uh in this series so it matters um so
tonight
uh hopefully you are re-energized and
ready i mean at least you have a week in
between them
uh because tonight we're going to be
talking about divine
violence that's the title of my message
uh so
i want to kind of frame our discussion
in
this way so i i do realize there are
those
uh and a lot of christian circles
perhaps even at the table um who
want to be kind of just done with the
apostle paul
for those who are unfamiliar so paul uh
was
one of the the greatest arguably early
christian missionary
game right after jesus and his writings
comprise roughly two-thirds of the
of the new testament um so he's you know
very influential
um and and folks who kind of are just
like ah i just don't i'm
kind of done here they would say
something maybe like this like jesus
i love jesus jesus i have loved jesus is
greatness
i can't get enough of those four gospels
but paul oh paul some of those letters
have parts i'm just not so sure about
and uh and she's like oh i mean even we
mentioned a few of those texts last week
um and so here's
in response this is what i'd say um i
understand
but i think we make a really grave
mistake
in abandoning paul because in so many
ways
he he really was one of if not the um
first christians to get it
what do i mean by it i mean that he
understood the just the radical nature
of what it meant to say that that god
however you want to phrase it god was in
christ was one with christ that god
became
flesh that that god came among us in the
person of jesus
and did what well paul
sees that he did the most surprising
thing in the world
the thing no one saw coming
uh in fact prior to his conversion
experience um not even paul himself like
brilliant phd theologian paul not even
he saw this coming
which is why honestly he fought
christianity for years
i mean he opposed this new christian
sect that had sprung up in the midst of
his religious culture
he opposed christians because even he
did not foresee
what god would do even paul the
religious zealot who had the entire like
old testament
and honestly he thought he had god down
like he knew god he knew his nature his
character
but even paul did not foresee the
radical thing god would do and in fact
it was so profound and
unnerving and unexpected and beautiful
that once he realized it paul said you
know what
from here on out this is the only way
i will declare who god is it's the only
way i will
speak to others of god and in fact
he said i've got to now go back to the
bible and
reread rethink everything
in light of this astounding fact
and what was that fact that god came
among us
in the person of jesus and yes his life
was remarkable
i mean his preaching miracles all
remarkable but
but but those things weren't like the
high point no the
highest revelation of god was this that
while we were yet sinners
while we jeered at christ
spat on him mocked the lord of glory
that
god who has all power who can do
whatever he wants
humbled himself as philippians 2 says
by becoming obedient to the point of
death even death on
a cross it was the cross
that's what paul got now
why does the cross matter
um you know tonight i won't even go into
all that it like means for
us you know the ways that christ on the
cross absorbed our evil and shame and
pain yes paul was interested in that too
but the radical thing paul named was
that the cross
uh it shifts the way
we understand god who we understand god
to be um how you you might say how we
image
god and if we asked paul uh paul
what what does god look like paul would
say
god looks like jesus hanging on
a cross he knew
uh it sounded like foolishness and in
fact if it doesn't sound like
foolishness to you that's only because
you're more christian than you realize
uh paul
he knew um i mean whoever heard of a god
who acted weak who ever heard of a god
humbling god's self in participating in
an
act of suffering love
who's ever heard of a god who would
rather die
than kill his enemies
that's that's a completely revolutionary
understanding of
god but paul got it
and he also got that in the ancient
world i mean this
was a radical departure from the way
most people understood god even
bible believe in people which is why he
writes in first corinthians chapter 1
verse 25
this is kind of a reflection it's a
meditation on the cross of jesus christ
and he says this just one verse the
foolishness of god
is wiser than human wisdom and the
weakness of god
is stronger than human strength
and in the verses just prior to this
paul says in fact to the secular
philosophical mind uh the cross is
it's just pure foolishness
and to the religious mind he says the
cross
is a stumbling block
it's a stumbling block i went for a run
about six weeks ago when it was still
blazing hot
although it was kind of hot today what
is up all right texas um now don't ask
me why after years of running in the
morning
i decided to switch that up in the month
of july i'm a stupid man
so anyway just one of those days where
you know it's 3 p.m and it's like 100
whatever
degrees and so i'm running on this trail
that kind of winds its way next to
a a golf course kind of through the
woods um and there
are these little wooden bridges that you
know steer you over the creeks and such
and so i think
it must have been the heat causing my
feet to drag
just a little lower than usual maybe
that's just an excuse
uh but no matter and then of course
there was this like little wooden board
um sticking up a little half inch or so
uh so there i am i'm huffing i'm puffing
along
and i come to that board and y'all it
wasn't even a stumble
i just flat out barrel rolled twice
it was just total wipeouts like just
and i literally had you know when you
have something really embarrassing but
you pop
up with a lot of confidence so that was
me i just kind of burn
and then i just kind of pop up like i'm
a man
and so i pop up with that confident look
that says nothing to see here
but i noticed i kind of glance around
because there's like various golfers
around and they're all like pause
mid-backswing just staring at me it was
so loud on that dumb wooden bridge
uh and so all right my point is
that that board that was my stumbling
block
right and so paul's saying for the
religious mind or what we might call the
biblical mind
the cross it's a stumbling block
notice he doesn't say oh the cross i
mean everyone saw this coming the most
logical thing in the world
he doesn't no no instead paul says to to
the religious mind
even the biblically informed mind based
on the old testament
the the cross it it trips us up
it it makes us stumble
um it disorients us why
because if you read through the bible
and presume you know it's all just
perfectly clear oracles of divine
revelations of god and god's character
then you would be on very strong
biblical grounds to say
no no the nature of the character of god
is not one
who absorbs human violence on the cross
but rather one who dishes it out to
others
exodus chapter 15 verse 3 puts it very
succinctly
the lord is a warrior the lord
is his name or leviticus chapter 26
verses 28-29
this is god speaking to the israelites
then in my anger
i will be hostile toward you
and i myself will punish you for your
sins
seven times over in other words whatever
you've done
i'm gonna pay back it like sevenfold
uh and then he says verse 29 you will
eat the flesh of your sons
and the flesh of your daughters
um he's referring here to a god-ordained
siege by a foreign army
where you know the people will be so
hungry basically they'll resort to
cannibalism even with their own children
um and but what he's saying right he's
saying like and make no mistake about it
when that army comes uh they they come
at my command here's ezekiel chapter 21
verses 3 through
7. this is what the lord says
i'm against you
it's quite an opening isn't it imagine
my uh me preaching on this passage like
all right let's
have our verse for the day and the lord
says i'm against you
it's kind of all right we're just going
he continues
i will draw my sword from its sheath and
cut off from you
both the righteous and the wicked
because i'm going to cut off the
righteous and the wicked
my sword will be unsheathed against
everyone from south to north
then all people will know that i the
lord have drawn my sword from its sheath
it will not return again
therefore grown son of man groan before
them
with broken heart and bitter grief and
when they ask you
why why are you groaning you shall say
because of the news that is coming
every heart will melt with fear and
every hand go
limp every spirit will become faint and
every
leg will be wet with urine
it is coming it will surely take place
declares the sovereign
lord now you might ask
what what is what was coming a slaughter
is coming divinely mandated violence
there's a passage this is isaiah chapter
63 verses one through six
um and just for a little context isaiah
is basically he's like seeing
a vision of what is to come
uh and so he asks who is this isaiah
says robed in
splendor striding forward in the
greatness
of his strength and then god responds
it is i proclaiming victory mighty to
save
and again isaiah asks what why are your
garments red
like those of one shredding the wine
press
god responds i have trodden the wine
press alone
from the nations no one was with me i
trampled them in my anger and trod them
down in my wrath
their blood splattered my garments and i
stained
all my clothing it was for me the day of
vengeance
the year for me to redeem had come i
looked but there was no one to help i
was appalled that no one gave
support god says so my own arm achieved
salvation for me and my
own wrath sustained me i
trampled the nations in my anger in my
wrath i made them
drunk and poured their blood
on the ground
now uh those are
you know we'll just say those are
intense um that might be pretty mildly
but
they're intense but i could um you know
i could imagine someone saying like well
you know humans can be slightly terrible
i mean are any of us really innocent so
you know maybe the people sort of had it
coming
um okay fair enough so here's um here's
a text that at least for me it
really kind of takes the cake um and by
the way i should give kind of a warning
that this
in the next passage um do kind of imply
basically sexual violence so just just a
heads up for anyone who might have had
trauma in this area
isaiah chapter 3 verses 16 and 17
moreover the lord saith because the
daughters of zion are haughty
and walk with stretched forth necks and
one tin that means like lustful eyes
walking and mincing as they go
and making a tinkling with their feet
the image theirs they might have like
bells around there
like on for anklets therefore verse 17
the lord will smite
with a scab the crown of the head of the
daughters of zion
and the lord will discover
their secret parts
um all right here's last one i can bear
to read from
for tonight this is jeremiah 13 24-26
and we'll jump back to verse 22.
so starting verse 24 god says to his
people i will scatter you like chaff
driven by the desert wind this is your
lot the portion i have decreed for you
declares the lord
because you have forgotten me and
trusted in false gods
i will pull up your skirts over your
face
that your shame may be seen
verse 22 and if you ask yourself why has
this happened to me
it is because of your many sins that
your skirts have been
torn off in your body mistreated
so i i don't know
how exactly all these texts are hitting
you
um this is one of the downsides doing
these messages like this i really would
love to get a read on the room right now
um you know but i'll just say for me a
little more than a decade ago
um it was versus like these and others
that did a number on me
uh in fact by some estimates there's
going to be close to a thousand verses
not quite this intense but um in a
similar vein of kind of
divinely mandated violence in the old
testament
and um these these passages
ba i mean they they destroyed me
after years of bible college at a very
conservative school
after years of being you know a fairly
conservative theologically conservative
youth pastor
i was preaching from the bible every
week and so i was coming across you know
these kinds of
passages even if i didn't preach them i
would kind of avoid you know
honestly as most pastors do i don't
think you've probably ever heard
many sermons on these um
and so you know there i was i mean i was
i'd come from this belief you know that
the entire
bible was this kind of inerrant flawless
perfect word of god and so
i started to take an honest look at
these texts and
uh the explanations of
why they were you know somehow kind of
justified
um just simply rang hollow for me
and so honestly i went a few years where
i could not read the bible
like at all that's right pastor brett
2008 to 2011 brett this is
very different than the bread that sits
before you now i just
couldn't i couldn't do it i just didn't
read the bible for years
um because because prior to that
i would be kind of reading along and of
course the bible can be magnificent
like it's it's it's you know the
magnificent verses are all the ones that
show up in your bible apps you know your
verse of the day app
you know those texts are great stuff
right um but i'd be reading along
and then i'd come to one of you know
these
and i would get
i mean honestly like for a while i was
confused and then i just reached the
angry stage
um in fact i can remember one time i
threw
my bible across the room i was like god
i am trying i'm i'm trying
but i don't know what to do with these
like you're a hot mess
and i don't know if you've ever been
there enough to throw your butt y'all
are probably more holy than me you
haven't thrown your bibles
um but i was i was angry
uh and and it was because honestly you
know at the end of the day
um my faith uh had really been
in the bible and and and it was really
you know the bible that was giving me my
image of god
like i said it was in jesus christ i
said my faith was in him
um you know christ crucified resurrected
that's all i need but really
um that wasn't really true it was it was
you know it was in the bible
and so when parts of the bible became
morally reprehensible to me
in the image of god i saw in places
became morally reprehensible to me
it was like my faith was was just
crumbling
around me
so what happened um well slowly
i i began to read christian theology and
and
learn and i realized there were very
different ways of approaching
not only these specific texts but really
the bible as a whole
um this of course goes back to um
message number one in this series
because you know from the earliest days
of christian faith
you have this um you know some called it
attention
uh not not attention but a tension
something called a contradiction between
like you know think of teachings of
jesus right things like
love your enemies and pray for those who
persecute you and then you have
these texts you know that effectively
say like kill your enemies and gloat
while you do it
it's you know i mean needless to say
it's it's
problematic right you have to be a
simpleton not to discern
hmm there's a problem here there's some
let's put it nicely attention between
these
so this kind of you know begs the
question like uh
yeah i see the problem brett but like
where does this where does that leave us
with the bible
um you know and with these these texts
of terror
so um in my kind of reading and thinking
this is
for the last 10 years this is some of
the the i'll call them
different approaches for how christians
down through the centuries
have um kind of handled the presence of
these
texts in the bible and tried to kind of
i don't know if reconciles the right
word but
but sort of explain or kind of make
sense of them in light of
um christ crucified and in the god we've
come to know
in jesus so i'm gonna give you four of
these approaches
tonight uh so number one uh god learned
comma god evolved i have no idea why i
just said comma
maybe um it's like ron burgundy when i'm
like looking at my notes for this point
and
god learned comma i'm run burgundy all
right anyway that's another pop culture
reference i've been giving y'all like
one pop culture reference per message
recently
all right god learned god evolved um
so the esteemed old testament scholar
walter brugerman
he says that he kind of makes this point
and i'm kind of paraphrasing
but he basically says like i think it's
that you know god learned you know
he sort of um god sort of tried the
coercive fear based
you know i will hurt you if you do not
obey route
and it got very mixed results and so the
bible is the history of god
um interacting with humanity and and you
know and kind of learning
um sort of over time you know god
discerns how to relate to
to his creation to his creatures um
so you can kind of think of this point
it's sort of like um parents who are
stripped
nearly to the point of abuse to their
firstborn
uh you know that firstborn like they're
whipped into shape
right but by the fifth kid the parents
have mellowed
and so brugamen would say something like
you know god learned god god mellowed
he learned like loving that's really the
right way to do this
okay you can probably tell from my tone
i think
um i think this is really problematic so
i think there's a few problems here
the main problem is that it it kind of
reduces
god um like from capital g
god to lower case to a lower case g
god uh what i mean by capital g god is
is really you know god as the source the
one the intelligence that gave rise to
everything that is the one in whom as
paul says we live and move and have our
being
this is kind of the classical
understanding of god where god is
all-knowing god is all present god is
all-powerful
and god is unchanging why unchanging
because when you change you you
presumably go
from the lesser to the greater or vice
versa right if you change
presumably you either got better or
worse um
but god is already pure goodness beauty
truth itself i mean you might even say
god is being itself he's not a super
duper powerful being right he is the one
from whom we came into whom we return
he's not superman right he's not a
really really really big
created being he's not zeus as i've uh
put it in many of my
letters in a few sermons god is not zeus
but when you say
you know something like bruggeman well
god you know god evolved god learned
um well if god learned then frankly he's
not god
at least not capital g god um
and he might be a lowercase g god like
poseidon or something
um but but he's not god if he learned
um and honestly you know another problem
with this option is that if god
changed we really can't trust him
can we because
well we might like this change but you
know what if later he decides to change
back
i mean maybe if he decides this
lovey-dovey stuff
it just didn't really work either right
so
i but this is one approach this is one
one route people take
um but but like i said there's a few
problems with this
um all right so that's the first
approach second approach uh is
is this that there are um there are two
sides to god so the idea here
is that yes jesus reveals god and yes
we learn something of god's character in
jesus and specifically of
of god's love right as jesus as paul
talked about dies on the cross for us
but someone might say with it but that's
just the loving side
the loving part of god
uh but there's another side
the the hidden side
the the angry the vindictive the violent
side this is what um carl bart referred
to
almost as though there's a god hiding
behind jesus
back or something you know um
so there's jesus but then
you know but then he doesn't really
fully reveal god there's this other
part jesus is super nice but you know
there's the other side to god
um you can really always leave it to the
artist to put it so powerfully the
musician tom waits who i have no idea if
he's a christian or not
um i'm guessing based on this text or
this quote that he's not um he writes
this there ain't no devil
there's just god when he's drunk
so uh i i think it's not too far of a
of a kind of summation of this view
right so i think you can see kind of how
problematic this is
um but but let me kind of spell it out i
think really the the issues here
are are twofold so a um if this is true
then god may be respected adhered to
obeyed and served um but never loved
right god would be almost like
almost like an abusive spouse who who
beats you up one day
and then comes back the next whispering
sweet nothings
right that's problematic
uh and this is why by the way i'm not a
calvinist
um just to throw that out there for any
theologically astute folks calvin had
this idea of
of as i referred to earlier the hidden
or dark or shadow side of god
and god's inscrutable will um
you know but if that's true then you're
you're kind of waiting for the other
shoe to drop
so so i think that's that's one issue um
with this line of thinking the other
uh is that honestly this just wasn't the
solution
of paul or john or any of the other new
testament writers
right they didn't say well well the old
testament reveals one side of god
and then jesus reveals another uh
and they're sort of in tension with each
other like like two wrestlers
you know within god kind of vying for
power no
no they did not say that uh instead as
we'll see shortly
they said jesus reveals god
full stop that was the route they they
um
took um now you might think well
okay maybe
maybe we just need to reject the old
testament seems like that's where a lot
of the problems are
we'll just be new testament christians
that brings us to the third
problematic approach which says the old
testament and its demigod
are to be rejected in favor of jesus
uh so this was the route of the infamous
um
marcian marcion was
later deemed a heretic by the church but
honestly people misunderstand marcion
you see like many christians basically
he knew the problem
uh posed by jesus's revelation of god as
opposed to the many problematic pictures
in the old testament
um i mean he knew this was a problem and
honestly that's fine um
everyone knew this was a you know as i
said earlier attention
a contradiction a kind of weird like oh
how do we make sense of this like
everyone knew that
um so so what was what was problematic
from
in marcion it was his solution
and his solution see he discerned the
problem correctly but his solution was
get rid of it all so he just basically
rejected the entire old testament
uh and he said i don't know what kind of
weirdness is going on here but this is
like some sort of demigod
who is like and you know fighting jesus
or something like he was
he was like we just got to get rid of
this whole thing um but but of course
like the story of jesus only makes sense
in light of the story of the old
testament
and so you can't just dismiss it all and
say like
clearly god was not at work then um
like he just yeah no no um that's kind
of an overreaction and so
uh and and frankly there's really great
theology in the old testament
right there's plenty of texts that line
up perfectly with the nature and
character of the god we've come to know
in jesus
and and honestly saying otherwise very
easily leads to religiously motivated
anti-semitism
right where you start to say things like
judaism bad
christianity good uh and that's that's
simply not the case
the the old testament is an absolutely
vital resource
um for for christians um
so so what do we need to do well i think
we need to join paul and john
and the early church fathers and mothers
and honestly even some jewish believers
like philo of alexandria
who although he wasn't a christian he
also was trying to make senses like you
know
how long ago 1900 years ago even philo
was trying to make sense of his own
jewish faith
and scriptures in light of back then it
was greek thought and he knew there were
certain things ascribed to god
in in the hebrew scriptures that were
unworthy of god's character and nature
so so even he had this approach and it's
what i'm calling and really have been
calling throughout the series
um the reinterpretative approach
so basically early christians said look
jesus is the highest the purest
the clearest revelation of god
when we see jesus we see the father
perfectly
he is the one in whom all other
revelations
find their end point he is the one in
whom they all culminate
he is also the one by whom we judge
all previous revelations because he
supersedes he is
greater than all previous revelations of
god uh here's a great example from the
book of hebrews this is uh
chapter one in the past god spoke to our
ancestors through the prophets at many
times and in various ways
so you can see though this is not
marcian right just saying like reject it
all he's like no no god
god was up to something god was speaking
um but
verse two but in these last days
he has spoken to us by his son
whom he appointed heir of all things and
through whom
also he made the universe the sun
is the radiance of god's glory and the
exact representation
of his being sustaining
all things by his powerful word
can you hear the difference there in
verses two and three that's
like i mean in other words what what is
this writer saying they're saying when
you've seen the character of
jesus you've seen the character of god
because he is the exact
representation of god's being right his
very
essence you've seen what love
looks like okay so what am i driving out
with all this
so i think this this kind of all begs
the question
um okay so if jesus reveals
who god is faithfully fully and
perfectly
um then why does the bible have those
passages in it that we read previously
right this would be the question why why
is there like and why is there this this
kind of trajectory
this this evolving changing
picture of god in the bible which if you
read it from front to back i mean you
can tell
this this is god seems to be in process
uh and back to walter bruggeman is it is
it god who changed
uh i don't think so instead
who changed
we did and and who got it wrong
did god mess up did god get it wrong
no no we did and who was violent
is god violent no
no god is a god who would rather hang on
a cross than kill his enemies
god is not violent who's violent
we are we are and we projected
our own issues our own rage
our own desire for vengeance
onto god and you might say well well not
me
i mean i didn't do that it was those
human all two human writers to which i
say well
you probably would have made the same
mistake so
so what does this mean for how we engage
the bible
well honestly for me it makes the bible
absolutely fascinating and interesting
and it's a text i read i mean as i've
said before nearly every day of my life
old testament new testament whole thing
and the holy spirit is
faithful to lead and guide me into truth
and when i come across something that
does not sound
at all like jesus when i come across an
image of god
that does not look like jesus hanging on
the cross whispering words of
forgiveness
over his enemies that does not look like
suffering love
well then i just say well
that doesn't look like jesus and i keep
moving
but i don't freak out and i don't leave
the faith
and and i certainly don't reinterpret
jesus and who he revealed god to be
to fit the text no no instead
i i engage the bible um
knowing that it is a text
wrestling with itself it's like a woman
in labor
struggling to give birth to the truth to
who god
really is which is why you can't stop in
genesis
or in the psalms or in isaiah
you have to keep reading the story to
find out
who god really is and in the gospels
we see the answer right god looks like
jesus
hanging on the cross that's
how the early church read the bible
let me pray for you lord jesus
i lift up every person who's hearing my
voice
and those who have maybe really really
struggled with how to image you
maybe they've come from traditions and
christian traditions that
um really emphasized this this idea of
a not very jesus-looking god
a wrathful god hateful vengeful
even violent and god i pray
that that they would come to see you
more clearly
more truly that they would know that you
are love through and through and through
god may that truth transform us as
individuals
as families as a church community
thank god may we become more and more
like you
love itself the life-changing name of
jesus christ i pray amen
[Music]
what does it mean if it
doesn't let mean death
please tell me if it
doesn't mean blood nails are
crying lonely
[Music]
what is it for if it
is not for breaking
if it's enough for pain
[Music]
nakedness
is being raised above my head
and i think this time
it's wearing someone else and see it
drop
into the ground and when it falls i hear
the sound
of someone crying
love you
[Music]
please tell me if it
doesn't sing of hope in healing
and forgiveness
[Music]
please tell me if
is being raised above my head
and i think this time
it's wearing someone else's here drop
into the ground and when it falls i hear
the sound
of someone crying
i love you the cross
i wear
and i think this time
it's wearing someone else i see it
dropping to
the ground and when it falls i hear the
sound
of someone screaming
i love you
[Music]
who is it for if it
is not for
[Music]
held us and
the fatherless
oh thank you so much um ladies that was
amazing
um and i want to thank you all for being
able to join us tonight
um and if you're in need of any kind of
support or
prayer at this time if you wouldn't mind
just
just message us at the table and we'll
have one of our leaders just follow up
with you
and also if you resonate with the
visions and the values of the table
we invite you to give online in order to
ensure the community can continue to
flourish
um you can do that at the website at
thetabletx.org
and i close with you tonight with this
benefit addiction
it is um found in ephesians which is
also written by paul
um at ephesians 6 it is 23-24
peace be to all the brothers and with
the love of faith
for the um whom the father god the
father
and the love of the lord jesus christ uh
grace be with all who love the lord
jesus christ
with love uncorruptable so be blessed
and have a fantastic week see you next
sunday
you